Hi, I'm Dan Zhang, a technical
account manager on the Android
Partner Engineering team.
And today, I'm here to talk to
you about how to maximize your
app's reach by designing for
devices with large displays.
This is the first of a
series of episodes.
And today, we'll focus on
different input methods.
As you know, the Android
ecosystem continues to grow.
More and more unique form
factors are coming onto the
market, providing a connected
continuum.
To name a few, there's already
smart TVs, set-top boxes, and
we're also starting to see in
the pipeline these Android PC
sticks, all-in-one smart
monitors, and, of course, our
own Google TV, which announced
at I/O this year that they're
migrating to stock Jellybean
Android later this year.
Now, these devices typically
provide non-touch input
methods, such as joysticks,
trackpads, D-pads, optical
mice, et cetera.
Now, the Android platform
provides facilities for
developers to target these
new use cases.
And that's what we want
to highlight today.
Now, these new form factors,
like smart TVs, are typically
designed for living room and
provide a 10-foot viewing
experience.
In other words, a
non-touch UI.
In the new Jellybean MR2 CDD,
we have a new definition for
the Faketouch input, which is
basically an alternative to
the conventional direct touch
interface and provides support
for point and click,
drag and drop
functionalities from a distance.
Developers should improve
their UIs
for Faketouch devices.
Again, the Android framework
provides a set of APIs to help
you define and collect
these input events.
We've listed a few
of them here.
We encourage you to read through
these CDD definitions
and framework APIs to understand
how to take
advantage of this
input method.
Now, in this simple table, we
listed changes you should make
to support the non-touch UI.
In your Android manifest, all
you need to do is make sure to
remove the touch feature
requirement unless it's
absolutely necessary
for your app.
And you should consider
Faketouch as an alternative
that provides more functionality
than the
traditional non-touch inputs,
such as D-pad, can provide.
Now let's quickly
look at a demo.
To simplify things, we're using
a Nexus 10 here with a
USB mouse to emulate the
Faketouch input.
This way we can work around the
Play Store filtering for
those apps that have not yet
declared Faketouch support.
So here, we have my favorite
variation of the Angry Birds
game, the Star Wars edition.
Let's continue a game
that has started.
As you can see, you can
perform just about any
functionalities you would
with a full touch UI.
That wasn't a very
good first try.
But let me try again.
So you could just fling the
birds away using your
Faketouch inputs.
But I should mention here that
you're not able to perform
multi-touch gestures in this
setup because I'm using a
simple mouse.
But with devices that support
multi-touch trackpads or
pointers, you will be able to
support these gestures, such
zooming in or zooming out.
So there you go.
Please look into Faketouch.
Now let's look at making your
apps more D-pad friendly.
Now, the D-pad has been
around long time.
Even in some of the original
smartphones,
they were built in.
And almost in all remotes, and,
obviously, USB keyboards.
So the reason we still want to
look at the D-pad is, even
with this new CDD definition,
some of the existing devices
still may not support Faketouch
for some time.
And even with the
Faketouch-capable devices, it
is often more effective and
easier for users to operate
remotes using just D-pad in the
living room environment.
Apps should respect all standard
key events for basic
navigation.
So how should we actually
optimize?
Now, one thing we should focus
on foremost is to address the
focus handling.
Basically, you want to make a
conscious decision where to
place the default focus to
minimize key presses.
The concept is simple.
We shouldn't always assume users
can randomly select an
area on your page using touch.
So we should utilize these APIs
listed here to request
default focus for certain
elements or explicitly take
over control for the
focus sequence to
traverse your pages.
Another optimization tip is to
actually change your layout to
be more D-pad friendly.
This is also not
a new concept.
And many apps designed for
tablets have already adapted
to this approach.
But again, the idea here is to
minimize the number of key
presses when a user tries to
traverse through the page in a
non-touch UI.
In this case, you can jump
forward in the tabs by
traversing just left to right
on the screen, which is much
faster than scrolling all the
way up or down through the
page using a D-pad input.
Again, to illustrate the
relationships between these
three input methods,
we've added D-pad
entry in this table.
If your app is fully D-pad
friendly-- in other words, you
can completely navigate
throughout your app using just
the conventional D-pad and don't
have to use any gestures
control, et cetera--
then you can simply declare just
no touch, or touch equals
false, in your Android
manifest.
And you may not need to
consider Faketouch.
But going back to the previous
example of Angry Birds, that
app is actually a good candidate
for using this new
Faketouch definition.
So now, let's do a quick demo.
This time, let's look at a
Google service, the Play
Movies app--
also one of my favorites.
I should mention that this app
has made a lot of improvements
in the last release
to support D-pad.
And as you see here
in a second--
so now, I've switched
to a USB keyboard.
And you can see I'm able to
traverse, sequentially,
throughout the app by changing
the focus on the top and
selecting content
I wish to watch.
Control playback [INAUDIBLE]
there you go.
So the movie has started.
So the escape key would take
me back one level, as you
would expect, just like
a touch input.
So this is what I would call a
D-pad friendly application.
So that's all I have
for you today.
Please stay tuned for
our next episode,
and thanks for listening.